il ya sept ans la vie de simon bessette
basculer un grand pas dans un pylône
il a reçu une décharge de plus de 300
mille volts le brûlant au troisième
degré soit plus de 50 % de son corps je
suis vraiment impressionné de voir que
l'accident qui a pu m'arriver qu'on ait
réussi à me sauver grâce à des greffes
de peau après un mois de coma il
s'éveille pour un deuxième choc le
miroir ne reflétera plus jamais l'homme
qu'il a été déjà juste d'apprendre ce
qui nous est arrivé c'est qu'on a frôlé
la mort qu'on a brûlé sur la moitié du
corps
c'est un très gros choc puis après
rapidement ben on commence à penser à
l'avenir dont on appréhende qu'est-ce
qu'ils envient lithium est utilisé sur
les grands brûlés ne restent pas
définitivement sur le tas siens ont fait
ce sont comme des bandages organique
qu'il protège pendant que sa propre peau
se régénère sont ces pamphlets tu mènes
beaucoup mourraient d'une infection en
temps de prélever de la peau sur le
patient mais la chose à ses limites
ainsi nous allons brûlures plus que
c'est en construction pour cent c'est à
dire c'est moi de 50% disponibles et
nous avons besoin de couvrir 50% ça
marche pas
la peau et prélever par héma-québec sur
des donneurs décédés avant d'être
congelé
héma québec voudrait en fournir
davantage au chum qui traite 75% des
grands brûlés du québec
s'ils crèvent cutanée son capital des
grands brûlés ont aussi besoin de
beaucoup de soutien psychologique
on a aussi le soutien d'un psychologue
et d'un psychiatre sur l'unité on a
quand même une grosse équipe avec la
physio l'ergot tout le monde se met
autour du patient pour l'aider le
soutien pyschologique en fait c'est tout
ça change tout moi j'étais hyper bien
entouré par mes proches mais aussi
sérieusement l'équipe médicale est
fantastique aujourd'hui simon termine
ses études en agronomie à l'université
laval
les prélèvements de tissus se font
automatiquement pour ceux qui ont signé
leur carte de don d'organes l'an dernier
on a pu réaliser 5000 greffe
grâce à 945 d'honneur et si michel
marsolais radio canada montréal